neues im fall maddie polizei sucht im
brunnen nach leiche außer dem
horrorcrash in hessen an diesem baum
starben drei teenager und wieder
hai-attacke vor australien das ist der
15 jährige surfer der zum opfer wurde ja
es sind wirklich schwere themen heute an
diesem samstag aber es könnte ein
historischer tag werden zumindest wenn
sich der verdacht der portugiesischen
polizei bestätigt es gibt nämlich neues
im fall maddie neue entwicklungen die
wichtig sind wichtige entwicklungen
angeblich gibt es fundamentale neue
beweisstücke und portugals polizei sucht
nun nach einem brunnen nach in einem
brunnen nach einer leiche möglicherweise
nach maddies leiche
das sind dramatische entwicklungen in
diesem fall maddie der schon als fast
unlösbar galt und in denen seit einigen
wochen zum glück 13 jahre nach ihrem
verschwinden an der algarve endlich
bewegung gekommen ist
zu diesem breaking news möchte ich jetzt
direkt auch mit unserem chef reporter
kai feldhaus sprechen kai betreut diesen
fall maddie schon seit zehn jahren
kaiser kunz wie heiß ist diese spur wie
ist es tatsächlich möglich dass eine
leiche jetzt in diesem brunnen gefunden
wird möglich ist alles natürlich man
würde sich wünschen dass dieser fall
endlich mal zu einem ende findet dass
das die eltern endlich mehr klarheit
bekommen es ist schon beachtlich dass
sie 13 jahre nach maddies verschwinden
jetzt dann doch nochmal so konkret an
einem ort gesucht wird es schaltet also
einen tipp zu geben
es scheint ein hinweis zu geben die
polizei entschuldigung jetzt nachgeht
wie heißt die spur ist das muss man dann
mal sehen ich bin nicht ganz sicher die
die die deutschen deutschen behörden
haben ja eigentlich angefangen
informationen einzusammeln nachdem sie
den verdächtigen den deutschen
verdächtigen der öffentlichkeit
präsentiert haben und gesagt habe wir
haben hier jemand erst gewesen sein
könnte die hinweise die jetzt
eingegangen sind die werden jetzt
chronologisch abgearbeitet und da wird
dann auch der hinweis auf diesen
expliziten brunnen in vila do bispo
dabei gewesen
das heftige ist ja auch dass kollegen
von uns diesen brunnen gefilmt haben und
gefragt haben warum sucht man da
eigentlich nicht nach einer leiche warum
warum hat man das nicht gemacht
ja das ist relativ einfach zu
beantworten glaube ich dass wenn die
kollegen diesen grund tatsächlich
gefilmt habe ist einfach gigantischer
zufall dass sie genau den daher starb
wir reden jetzt nicht vom dorfbrunnen
von praia da luz von dem einen grund den
star gibt da hat jedes häuschen im
portugiesischen hinterland das sehr
zersiedelt ist seine eigene system da
seine eigenen wasserzugang der noch
genutzt wird oder auch nicht wenn man
die alle durchsuchte das ist die nadel
im heuhaufen und vila do bispo das sind
15 kilometer bis plus also jetzt auch
nicht gerade in lauf in lauf entfernung
das heißt man hat es wahrscheinlich
einfach nicht geschafft sämtliche
branchenportal also die suchen und dass
unsere kollegen jetzt genau diesen
brunnen abgeführt haben ist nämlich ein
gigantischer zufall
aber ich glaube da kann man der polizei
keinen vorwurf machen kann wie viele
andere vor ihr machen dass sie damit mit
spuren nicht so sorgfältig umgegangen
sind aber dass sie in diesen brunnen
nicht geguckt haben das kann man ihnen
jetzt nicht unbedingt verhalten